now a piece in politico caught my eye
this morning noting that as the midterm
elections pick up democrats are calling
for more police funding and attempting
to co-opt traditionally republican
talking points on crime good luck now if
you had any reservations about just how
callous
and calculating the democratic party is
let that passage put it to rest because
for two years post george floyd they let
the bodies pile up across this country
and only when it became politically
expedient did they call for more police
joining us now is arkansas senator tom
cotton a member of the judiciary
committee senator
this should be a warning should it not
to any voter
who thinks that democrats truly care
about crime
when in this new york case they still
can't say
anything clear about this guy's motives
when he tells us what his motives are
online
i mean it couldn't be more obvious what
the guy was trying to do
i know laura it's an amazing change of
heart the democratic party is not going
to be tough on crime i'm just waiting
for them tomorrow to announce that
they're going to protect unborn babies
and protect your second amendment rights
as well i mean i just can't even believe
this is happening but here's what all
voters should keep in mind it's not
actually happening this is just campaign
spin from democrats because they
recognize that americans are prepared to
hold them accountable at the ballot box
the fact that we have the highest
increase in the murder rate on history
that in so many cities now parents are
worried about letting their kids go play
in parks or whether their kids can walk
home safely from school or from a ball
game back home as it's getting dark
that's the direct result of democratic
policies whether it's defunding the
police or eliminating bail systems or
cutting sentences for drug dealers just
a couple weeks ago the president's own
chief of staff gave a speech celebrating
that they had just let out more felons
from federal prisons than any
administration in history so despite
what the democrats are saying now the
american people know the democrats are
always have been soft on crime and that
is endangering americans yeah and it's
always that
they claim well republicans want to
criminalize poverty
that's the line from the progressives
in new york and baltimore
oakland
st louis
that they're the callous ones
when in fact the callousness and the
danger comes from this revolving door of
criminality
and that suspect in new york his rap
sheet was quite long he had a
ties to new jersey and pennsylvania and
wisconsin ohio and chief
of detectives james essig said that
he has nine prior arrests in new york
three in new jersey and two states where
it was just released uh so happen to
have very lacks
bail policies even with some reforms
that they say are coming
uh so the the the stats tell the story
do they not
yeah yeah laura republicans don't want
to criminalize poverty it's democrats
that don't want to criminalize anything
you have prosecutors supported by george
soros in places like philadelphia and
san francisco in los angeles that
refused to prosecute entire categories
of crimes in many cases
serious and even violent crimes
those are the prosecutors that are
contributing to the rise of increase in
their cities it's not republicans who
who've been proposing to for instance
eliminate cash bail in places like new
york which they did and has resulted in
that revolving door of serious criminals
being arrested and then immediately
being released and committing crimes
again
this is what the democratic party stands
for remember kamala harris was bailing
rioters and arsonists out of prison in
minnesota two years ago encouraging her
supporters to give money to bail funds
in minnesota for blm riders to get out
of prison
now senator it's great to see you
tonight thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else